pour les plus jeunes ces téléviseurs
peuvent avoir l'air de venir d'un autre
monde des années 50 à aujourd'hui la
télévision a bien changé dans son
contenu et dans sa forme en témoigne ce
pique nique ce téléviseurs de philips a
connu son heure de gloire dans les
années 60
c'est un téléviseur qui date de 1969 et
qui est tout à fait emblématique de
l'évolution du poste de télévision dans
les années 60 avec l'apparition de
nouveaux matériaux cas notamment le
plastique qui remplace le bois pour ceux
de la génération précédente
et puis cette forme tout à fait épuré
futuriste vous faites dans une
simplicité de 2,2 forme
c'est dans les années 70 que les
français s'équipent massivement de ce
nouveau média
le musée de la ville raconte son
histoire dans une exposition le rôle de
la télévision a été essentielle lors de
la création de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
notamment par l'intermédiaire du crabe
et de la bac ce qu'ils étaient
des associations des structures locales
qui ont permis d'utiliser l'audiovisuel
et en particulier l'image télévisuelle
comme outil d'expression la population
vis-à-vis de la construction de cette
usine de cette ville nouvelle qui était
en train de se construire un retour
nostalgique et au temps où les
téléviseurs trôner fièrement dans les
salons
c'est désormais dans nos poches où notre
sac qu'il se décline une nouvelle
génération toujours aussi porté sur les
écrans